so we're heading to this like
orientation thing for the hololens ren
really wanted to be here so we put
together a pitch document for tether i
sent them over to
some friends they came back and they
said hey tether's cool we should make
something so that's cool that's really
cool so we're gonna probably pursue that
and you guys will finally get your
tether movie hopefully a movie there's
so much confusion these days about
movies and series and which one's better
and so everybody tries to do both nobody
cares about movies unless they're in the
theater places like hulu and netflix and
all these other places that are
they're buying series they're not buying
movies but at the same time series are
obviously way more of an undertaking
writing wise and production wise than a
movie is
[Music]
we're rocking the red dragon this is
basically a cinema level camera
oh boy look at the guy hold on i gotta
get some sniping practice
i lost it
there it is
look at that landing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna have to land soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
this is like a new version of reality
hey
oh
i may have touched something turned off
i don't know how see god damn it i
didn't press anything
i broke it i turned it on
say next to begin
oh i said it okay
see now i have to calibrate it right now
thanks to ren hitting a button face an
open area sorry guys one second i'm sure
there is a button niko the problem is i
don't think i can turn it off in the
middle of calibration
oh there he goes yeah how are you doing
it just mapped you in the wall behind
you oh yeah
i'm the thing i'm actually super shocked
about
is how good the tracking is
this is how you use computers in the
future stay in the corner by yourself
and
mutter things under your breath
so you just you set the window down you
can walk up to it
i would like to point out that i
didn't know how to use it hey cortana
start recording boop
boop
i want to take that helmet i'm going to
spin it around so if these guys crash
here if they smash them to the side of
the bridge
their drones going into the river this
is really a scene where they have to do
something dangerous
and they have to do it without crashing
because the drone's gone if they do